So let me take you back into what we
were talking about last time. We were talking about
the iterated prisoners dilemma, and here's the prisoners dilemma
payoffs that you wrote down for us. You remember this?
>> I vaguely remember this.
>> And remember it was about these two criminals, Smooth and Curly. And they
were, deciding whether to cooperate or defect
against each other when, after they've been arrested.
>> Right, and they defect, they always defect. They always
defect, right. So in particular, we say well what happens if it's, if they have
multiple rounds in which to interact, and so here they are, here are the two
of them, and if they've got one round to live, we did an analysis and
we indicated that there's really nothing they
can do other than defect against each other.
>> Mm-hm.
>> It's irrational to do anything else.
>> Yep.
>> So we said, all right, well, what happens if we allow
there to be more than one round? So now we've got two rounds.
And what we realized was that if you got
two rounds to go, then these players essentially, face a
one-round game because, after this round, what they're going to do
in the last round has already been determined. So it's
almost as if that round doesn't really matter. There's nothing
we can do now that's going to change what they're going
to do in that last round, so it's sort of
like there's just one round and we're going to defect again.
>> Right, so life is terrible and everyone is out to get everyone else.
>> Exactly, and
not only is it for two rounds, but this
same argument continues as you go three rounds or more.
>> Oh, it's like a proof by induction.
>> It's kind of like a proof by induction, yeah, well it's proof by ellipsis.
>> Mm, that's my favorite kind of induction. Proof by ellipsis.
>> [LAUGH] So the question then becomes, what
happens if the, number of rounds left is unknown,
right? So what we've realized is that if
you know how many rounds are left, the whole
thing comes unraveled and they're just going to defect forever. But we raised
the issue of, what happens if the number of rounds left is unknown?
>> Hm.
>> And it seems like it shouldn't really make any
difference because if it's say some finite number we just
don't know what it is, then it seems like it
should still reduce to this same setup that we have.
So I was looking into this and it turns out
that is it's not the case it actually does make
a difference and it's, it's really interesting how it goes
and how it connects back with other things we've talked about.
>> Woo, tell me more.